there are now seven point seven billion
people on the planet that's more than
twice as many as in 1970 over the same
time wildlife populations have decreased
by an average of sixty percent our
runaway consumption of energy land and
water is killing nature according to WS
Living Planet report species such as
rhinos African Grey parrot white rump
vultures and Bornean orangutans are all
in decline Latin America and the
Caribbean home to the Jaguar and the
giant anteater are worst-affected with
populations of monitored species down by
89 percent their habitat the tropical
forest is shrinking trees are being
replaced by farmland palm oil for
processed foods and soya beans for
animal feed and take a look at this
livestock is replacing wildlife of all
the mammals in the world apart from us
96% of cattle sheep and pigs just 4% of
wild species the the loss of habitat in
one past world as well as being driven
by what happens in another past the
world also impacts them what happens in
those possible so for example you know
losing the Amazon rainforest would be
absolutely catastrophic from the point
of view of tackling climate change so it
matters to all of us that we should make
sure that these key parts the world are
not damaged any further the oceans are
in decline to 6 billion tons of fish
shellfish and other creatures have been
taken from the Seas since 1950 with
industrial fishing pushing some
populations to collapse warming seas
driven by climate change a killing coral
by mid-century 90% of reefs could be
gone and as we've highlighted with the
sky ash and rescue campaign plastic is
being eaten by fish turtles and whales
and as I found off the Welsh coast
gannets
even raising their chicks in nests of
discarded fishing nets with tragic
consequences in two years time nations
will gather for the United Nations
Convention on Biological Diversity WWF
says habitats need protecting an economy
made more sustainable to reverse the
decline in wildlife